Okay, so
we have seen that we want coherence, and
now the question is how do we get it?
So how do we make
caches become coherent?
The first option is don't do caching,
but this is really bad for performance,
so we will not seriously consider this.
But if there are no caches, then all
of the accesses go to memory, and
then writes to that memory will be
seen by the reads to that memory.
And also, the order in which the memory
receives the writes is the order in
which the writes will be seen by all the
cores, so the system will be coherent.
The second option is if all cores
share the same level one cache,
then the same argument for
coherence applies.
The order of writes is the order
seen by this level one cache.
And all of the accesses are going to
go to the same cache where they see
the same version of the block.
So the system will be coherent, but
will still have really bad performance,
better than this, but not by much.
Now we can try do do things
like having private caches,
but make them write through.
In that case, the memory's actually
seeing all the writes, but
the problem is that these
caches are still allowed
to cache data that has
only been read forever.
So once we read the value, it doesn't
matter that all the other cores
are writing their values through
to memory, because the cache that
only reads will potentially see forever
the same failed value even after many,
many writes have occurred,
and for a long time.
So this is really not
a way to get coherence.
Even with write-through caches, private
caches are not necessarily coherent.
What we must do really,
is to force reads made to one cache
to see the writes made in another.
So we cannot allow caches to simply
provide a same value over and
over once it's a cache hit.
Somehow, once a write occurs
in one cache, another cache
needs to eventually start returning
that value to its local processor.
So how do we do that?
One way is for every write to
be sent to all the other caches
that might potentially have this block,
and they need to update their value.
So pretty much I write to my cache.
It's kind of like a write-through cache
in that it continues past the cache.
But now what really happens to it is not
only does it get rid of backup memory,
it also gets sent and
seen by all the other caches,
which now take that new value.
If that happens, then when I write,
other caches now have my new value,
and then reads on those scores will
actually provide the same value.
This is called write-update coherence,
because writes updates all
of the other cache copies.
The other approach for maintaining
coherence is for writes to prevent
other copies of the block
from having hits.
So after I write one cache,
all of the caches that
had a copy of this block need to
behave like they're having a miss, or
they need to behave like the block
is not valid in that cache.
So this is called write-invalidate.
A write will invalidate
all the other copies.
Note that these are just
the two general approaches.
We will be looking at several
write-invalidated coherence protocols,
and also we will be considering
a write-update protocol.
So this ensures, really, that reads
see the values produced by writes.
So the coherence property two is
maintained by either this or this.
So we need to pick one
of these two approaches
to maintain coherence property two.
For coherence property three, we need to
decide what's the order of writes and
all the cores need to
see the same order.
One way to enforce the same order of
writes being seen by all the cores
is that all writes are broadcast on the
shared bus, and then the order in which
they appear in this shared bus is the
order that should be seen by everybody.
Coherence done in this
way is called snooping,
because when writes
are broadcast on the bus,
everybody snoops those writes in order
to tell what order they occurred on,
and also to update or
invalidate their values in the cashes.
Of course, the shared bus
can now become a bottleneck.
The other approach is that each block
is assigned an ordering point, and
different ordering points can
be used for different blocks.
So that for each block, all accesses
are ordered by the same entity.
But different blocks use different
entities, so they don't have contention.
This ordering point is called
Directory when doing coherence.
So this family of approaches is
called a Directory Based Coherence.
And this directory both serves
as an ordering point for
a block, and also figures out
who to update or invalidate.
When multiple caches have a version of
the same block, an overwrite occurs.
So among these two approaches,
we can also pick one.
And indeed all four possibilities,
this and this, this and this, this and
this, and this and
that, are all possible.
So you can have write-update with
snooping, write-update with directory,
write-invalidate with snooping,
write-invalidate with directory.